[inaudible].
Joining me today is an author,
the editorial director of the American Institute for Economic Research as well
as a senior fellow at the Austrian economic center.
Jeffrey Tucker.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
Good to be here.
I almost wore the same bow tie,
my friend Healy.
I should've brought one extra right there for you.
That would have been
all right.
There's a ton I want to talk to you about your,
your sort of a,
one of these people that are right around all of the topics that I'm talking
about from the freedom and liberty and free speech and the battle between the
left and the right and all that,
but your new book and I want to get the title absolutely correct.
Right wing collectivism,
the other threat to liberty.
I thought that would be the spot for us to kick this off because most of the
people watching this show know that I've mostly focused on the left.
Sure,
sure.
Was My home or it was it progressive.
I've woken up to what I should.
Real liberalism is obviously,
and that has nothing to do with the modern left.
But sometimes people say,
Dave,
you don't critique the right enough.
So let's dive in.
What's interesting about talk about anyway is that so often the left and the
right are not as distinguishable as they seem to be for,
for example,
uh,
the,
this,
this trade stuff.
You know,
Elizabeth Warren and Donald Trump basically agree.
How do you account for that?
And,
and now we,
you see all the celebration of the working classes,
you know,
you're going to get again,
uh,
the Trump Ian bride agreeing with the Bernie Sanders on,
on that,
uh,
the left is ever more trending nationalist and its immigration policies,
for example,
that didn't use to be the case.
So how was the left?
Well,
shouldn't listen to him.
like Bernie Sanders complained that free free immigration is,
is a coke or coke industries plot basically to provide the capitalist class
cheaper workers,
for example.
Now that you would've never found anybody on the left 20 years ago saying that,
but,
but now you know what's happening.
You know the,
the,
the hatred of the,
of,
of commerce and,
and the merchant class is so intense now that if a luxury resort and um,
in Florida wants to hire some,
some immigrants to work for them,
then the left is saying,
oh no,
this is,
this is terrible cause this capitalist capitalism at work.
So he was trying to see this strange blending.
The left and the right have different cultural pitches,
a different appeals to different constituencies,
but they both have this agenda that's,
that boils down to the,
to the use of power.
Is this a little bit of just what people refer to as the horseshoe theory that
the more that the sides had become sort of extreme,
that they're oddly [inaudible] I've heard this,
this horseshoe there.
I tend to think that's a little bit superficial.
I mean,
I look at it a little bit more historically and you see,
since since liberalism is born in the world and the 18th century,
really high middle ages,
but when the revolt against liberalism began the early 19th century,
right,
too much change,
too much wealth,
the wrong people are getting rich,
then there's not enough control.
What are we going to do about our religion,
our language,
our rates.
You know,
the,
the revolt began to grow from about the 18th,
20th,
and intensified and spread,
uh,
to the United States.
Britain really began to take root and continental Europe.
There they took two forms.
So there was a left form and a right form.
And in each country they took,
they took on different iterations of different names,
you know,
so,
so in Britain you had the Tories,
then you had to lay a Labour party.
They both wanted to use the state for their own purposes.
Then you always had the opposition party,
which was the liberals and you know,
and,
and that's the way it's fleshed out itself.
In country after country.
The Liberal Party has always been,
the people said,
why don't we just let society be,
let people live their lives,
let them choose a religion of their own,
of their own choice.
If they'd all hurting anybody,
that's not a problem.
Let's have free speech.
This have a universal rights.
I have rights for this.
This get rid of slavery.
Let's have rights.
Acknowledging the existence of women's rights.
Uh,
equality of freedom for everybody.
Leave everybody alone.
That's the liberal position.
That's a pretty good position.
It's,
it's a,
it's a beautiful position and it's,
and it's what I favorites,
but I think it's what built civilization coming out of the religious wars or the
high middle ages,
we discovered this idea of freedom.
We tried it,
it worked.
But there's,
but there's,
uh,
there's always been a revolt brewing against it.
A resentment,
uh,
resentment against it and get resentment against the commercial class.
Too much change,
too much wealth,
wrong.
People getting wealthy.
We're not controlling demographics well enough.
There's not enough to quality whatever the thing is.
It takes different forms in different countries and in different times in
different places.
But ultimately the right and the left are ideologies of control and power and
liberalism has always been the alternative to that.
So,
so we keep having to rediscover this again and again and every generation.
Yep.
Well that's why now I'm so happy that there is,
as you said to me right before we started the phrase classical liberalism is
coming back.
You know what I mean?
You hear it on TV every now and again.
I like to think that maybe I had a little something to do with it.
You know,
and I mean to me it is the only current antidote to the problems that we have,
either the more state power that the democratic socialist want as they've sort
of ransacked their own party and purged all of the Liberals.
And it's also the antidote for all of the people.
If you think Trump is all of the horrible things that people say about him all
the time,
what's the antidote?
The antidote isn't to get somebody else.
And then more power to power.
The antidote obviously is to take power away from that.
That's what liberalism
I hope is that,
that there are the good people left the center of the left that are looking at
the emergence of the Trump problem.
Uh,
we'll reconsider,
uh,
the uses of power and the executive state.
And why did we build this gigantic machinery of the total state if it's so
vulnerable to being captured by our enemies.
Right,
right.
That's what we,
that's the real question that we're at right now.
If you believe this thing has been captured by the Russians or whatever it is,
it's like,
well,
okay,
you're kind of answering your own questions.
So I hope that we can,
we can rekindle a kind of a new resurgence or I do have to credit you and Jordan
Peterson for this.
I mean,
I've been working at it for about 10 years to try to bring back to the,
not just the term liberal,
but the concept of liberalism,
um,
to,
to public life.
And,
uh,
but it's been difficult because,
because,
because we do have the state that creates a kind of moral and intellectual and
ideological hazard.
Somebodies got to control it.
And now that we,
we built it over the last hundred years,
this,
this total state of massive taxes,
regulations,
interventions,
uh,
running people's lives.
Everybody's trying to get hold of it and grab it and beat up their enemies.
And it's a problem.
It's a serious problem.
So when people say to me,
and we've discussed this on the show a bunch of times before,
and I've dressed,
addressed this and several forums,
when people say to me,
wait a minute,
when you're,
when you say you're a classical liberal,
and you talked about laissez faire economics and getting the government out of
the way and all those things,
really,
this is just a repackaged libertarianism,
or you're just afraid to say that you're a conservative because it's still not
cool,
or something like that.
Is it,
how would you define the difference between,
say,
a classical liberal and a libertarian?
And let's talk about that because,
uh,
because after World War Two,
these neoliberalism logistics,
these new terms came along,
uh,
one was conservatism.
It wasn't really used before the early 1950s,
Russell Kirk's book called,
um,
uh,
the mindset of a conservative simply like the conservative mind.
I think it was what it was called.
And Libertarianism was again,
uh,
first used in about 1957,
um,
by the translator of the works of Boston had,
the problem was the term liberal had been captured by the new dealers as early
as 1933.
Once they acquiesced to the idea of the corporate of estate and we're blaming
the great depression on capitalism,
um,
that became a problem for liberalism that kept the term liberalism,
but they were no longer liberal cause they were suddenly for big government,
there were four big government and even worse,
the corporate state.
And actually we can just be more blunt about it and say that back in the 1930
[inaudible] this,
this ideology had a name.
The name was fascist.
Okay.
So,
so they caved,
right?
I mean in the New York Times in 1933 the New York Times magazine was celebrating
the great prep professor,
Mussolini,
and how he and FDR shared a vision for the planned economy.
So that's the world we were living in back then.
So we,
we lost the term liberal after World War Two.
There was an attempt to,
to just speak a language and to,
and to,
to describe who we are.
And on one hand you had this new thing called conservatism and they,
they,
they kind of sampled some of this Tori,
Tori likeness Ostalgie for the past,
a little bit of revanchist them,
you know,
let's recapture what we've lost.
Then on the other hand,
you had the genuine liberals and they coined the term libertarianism,
which had been sitting on the shelf since the late 19th century.
Now most of the people who call themselves libertarians in the late 19th century
America and England were anarchists,
socialists,
but nobody had bothered with the term for decades and decades.
So Dean Russell's said,
well,
nobody's using that word.
Why don't we use it?
And that was closer to the truth of what they were in effect.
Well,
what was interesting about that is as Dean Russell described it in his 1957
article,
it was a synonym for what was once called liberal.
He didn't think it was a tweak or an improvement or a distillation or refinement
or a new dogmatic way of describing the bulls and he thought it was liberalism.
So I need to read that because I mean that's how I feel.
I don't know if someone sends me,
Dave,
you're a libertarian.
I don't mind that.
If we need labels,
I don't mind that late,
but I don't mind the,
I believe we can split the difference on how much government sure she'd be.
The problem.
I think libertarianism as a number,
as a term has number of problems.
One is it's a little clinical sounding and it has too many syllables and it
makes you sound a little bit awkward and it sounds maybe a little too canonical.
You know,
like we,
we have a list of things you have to believe,
you know,
like this,
this,
it's all rooted in this kind of reductionist,
uh,
more commonly these days.
It's rooted in this kind of reduction.
That's nonaggression principle,
which is a fine principles or rule of thumb,
but it's not a good,
it doesn't describe the whole of life.
So,
uh,
the other problem is that libertarianism is,
is a new term so it doesn't have a deep history.
So we can't look back and say,
oh,
look,
the libertarians freed the slaves,
the Libertarians,
uh,
acknowledged to the rights of women.
The Libertarians gave us the commercial society that built the middle class and
brought dignity to the average person.
You know,
if they had existed as a party,
they would have done those,
they would have done this.
But it means the liberals who did that,
but it's deliberate when we changed our name,
so now we can like feel a sense of pride in our path so it doesn't have a past.
Hmm.
So that's a problem.
So we're,
libertarians tend to be detached from their own history for that reason.
And I think it's a problem.
It's a word problem.
The second problem is that libertarianism doesn't have a universal of usage.
Like where's liberalism does,
you can go to Spain described herself and liberal Brazil.
There's,
there's liberals in Germany,
there's liberals,
every,
there's a word for liberalism and every language and it more,
less means the same thing except in the United States.
Right?
So,
uh,
so,
if we acquiesce to this term libertarian and just wipe out our liberal history,
we're cutting off cells off both from the world and from our own history.
It's so funny because you've just said it in a far better way than I think I've
ever really laid it out.
But people will say to me,
Dave,
stop saying you're a liberal and I don't want to stop saying I'm going to,
I get that.
I'm fighting an uphill battle right now,
right?
I'm a,
I'm a salmon swimming upstream.
This is going to be tough,
but I don't want to deny what is the truth just because,
because it's tough.
It's who you are and you want to,
you want to have an ancestry,
you know,
you want to look back and,
and see,
uh,
the,
the champions are the Meta cheese and 15th century Florence and say,
I know those people.
Those are my people.
You know,
the people who long for a world without slavery.
in the early 19th century that people who want free trade,
him fought hard for it.
Those are our people.
That's our history.
I mean we were,
we were born as part of a long stream of emancipation that's been taking place
for 500 years.
That's our movement,
our people,
our history.
Let's embrace it.
I'm with your brother.
Yeah.
All right.
So are there any of those liberals uh,
part of the Democratic Party anymore?
Dude,
those people exist.
Strange things are happening on the left.
Very strange thing.
So now I'm not sure I should pause you for one sec.
My original question here was I wanted to do the deep dive on their right.
So we're going to get know we will get,
no,
I promise you we're going to get today on our topic.
I mean,
the deep dive of the far right gets us into a very dark place.
Yeah.
All right,
well maybe that.
so maybe the whole second half will be on that.
Let me just put that out there right now.
That's what we'll do for the second.
He's not getting out of my depression having done my book.
It was terrible.
All right,
so our whole second half is going to be what my first question was about,
but let's just keep going.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
For now.
So,
so strange things have happened to the left.
Um,
let's just mention that the,
the phrase cultural appropriation for example.
Now when,
when did that,
the approbation of this idea of cultural appropriation?
Kellogg,
what,
two,
three years ago?
Three,
four,
five.
I Dunno,
I could me as weird.
It may have been brewing for 10 years,
but when I first heard about it,
I thought that is the craziest bunch of nonsense I've ever heard.
I mean,
civilization is nothing but cultural appropriation of,
we've been doing this since,
since the ninth century.
You know,
at the,
at the height of,
of the Cup of Vinci.
I'm,
it's in Spain where Judaism and Islam and Christianity came together in this
beautiful melting pot where we all learn from each other in the cultures began
to blend in.
Our religions began to change and our,
our outlook on life began because we learned from each other.
If we stay isolated on our little tribes,
we're never going to progress.
And,
and the idea that,
and I don't know if it was or what happened,
we can talk about this,
but when,
when suddenly you're told you cannot have affection for another culture and take
what you find valuable and learn,
learn for yourself and live a better life,
that is very strange.
They seem to think it's cultural and annihilation,
not cultural appropriation,
right?
Like they seem to think that this is something that will lead to the destruction
of that culture,
when in fact it actually spreads the ideas of culture,
the foods,
the thing,
the,
the ideas that just they're creating culture as a scarce.
Good luck.
It's a property,
but it's not the magic of culture,
which is the same magic of ideas is resides in its infinite reproducibility and
its malleability.
This is something that the world of ideas can do that the physical world cannot
do.
And if we don't make that distinction,
we're going to get very confused.
Do you see what I mean?
Cultures spread their infinite,
uh,
and they can constantly change.
And that's the magic and beauty of,
of culture.
We,
we can't get that out of this class of water,
this table right there.
They're bound by the constraints of scarcity.
But the world of ideas is,
is magical.
It's like a constant,
constant,
infinite sandstorm,
you know,
unpredictable.
And I'm constantly changing and we can,
we can take
a culture for ourselves without taking it from somebody else.
Right.
It's just,
it's,
it's reproduction,
reproduction.
It's infinite reproduction.
So loaves and the fishes isn't,
isn't the beauty to that.
America has done this better than anyone,
perhaps in the history of the world.
You just referenced some other points in time,
but that we have taken in more cultures.
And you said the phrase melting pot.
I mean that,
that's what we designed and set up here,
the most beautiful melting pot ever.
I lived in New York City for most of my life,
most of my adult life at least,
and would be on subway cars.
And you are on that car with absolutely everyone with,
I have white guys with dreadlocks and the whole thing.
And guess what?
You may not like everybody and you may not like the way this guy smells and that
person may be doing this,
but we're all there.
But a man living together,
it's magic.
You know?
It's,
it's,
it really,
it's commerce.
It's because this country elevated the commercial ethos to be the highest thing
that great and noblemen factor of,
of,
of human life.
And it's commerce that brings people together.
And we experienced that every day.
You know,
you can,
in a,
in a commercial setting,
people aren't fighting each other.
They're,
they're getting along.
I mean,
I find I'm with you.
I go to,
I go to a restaurant and I get served by some guy from,
from,
uh,
Pakistan.
It's,
it's a chance to meet somebody new.
It's a chance to engage somebody and I have a personal relationship with
somebody who's serving you and you're serving them and you experienced this
magic of exchange.
Uh,
Benjamin consultant used to talk about this and the 1830s,
how,
how commerce brought to the world and new understanding of freedom and a new
opportunity for us to find value in each other,
in service of each other and Co and America just flourished and commerce.
And that's why,
that's why we have the diversity and the,
and this melting pot as you call it.
And this rich cultural life.
You know,
it's so funny because I'm so keenly aware of it right now.
Not only because of the conversations I'm having and because people are
screaming about this stuff all the time.
But you know,
I'm on this tour with Jordan Peterson and when I go to every airport that I go
do I,
90% of the time,
unless someone's had a car for me,
I take an Uber and I just hop in whatever Uber shows up.
And there is there,
there is every single type of person that looks every which way.
And as Chlorella,
every sexuality.
And usually I talk a little bit to,
to them it's,
you know,
and it's like,
man,
these are just people.
I maybe feel the same way.
You know,
I live in Atlanta,
which is just a gigantically diverse society,
you know,
and everywhere you go,
you're bumping into people who are different from you and,
and hang around in crypto circles in Atlanta.
I want to talk to you and that you're talking about a melting pot.
I mean,
we're all together and we all consider each other are people,
you know,
just because we all love crypto and it has nothing to do with,
with race.
You can appreciate racial groups
Francis with,
but also see value in everybody and,
and hope they can see value in you.
You can come together.
It doesn't mean that we have to be egalitarian or,
or denied differences.
It means that we find strength and our heterogeneity.
And,
and that's,
that makes for a beautiful unexciting life.
One of the strangest thing that's happening now,
you know,
with the rise of the alt right in response to the failures and,
and strange.
And so the left is this new celebration of homogeneity as if,
oh,
we need to live in a unitary racial state,
you know where we all speak the same language are all have the same religion.
So that's tracks me as aesthetically very boring and I don't,
I don't even recognize what that world would look like and feel like.
And it doesn't appeal to me in the slightest bit.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
was built out of the,
I don't have the diversity that grows out of commerce and the commerce is the
key because that's what helps us invest in each other.
You know,
Adam Smith said this about the division of Labor,
right?
It's like what causes wealth?
The division of Labor,
how big can that be?
It should be as big as possible.
The wider the division of Labor,
the more people you include in the great project of,
of building commercial life and production,
the wealthier we're all going to be together.
And I just,
I love that vision.
So when
we talk about capitalism on the show,
I'll every now and again I'd jump in the comment section or I see what people
say on Twitter.
If I have,
you know,
some of the ion ran people on or just some of the people
that are not for regulation at all.
And just let the economy go and see what happens.
There's always a certain amount of people that say,
okay,
that all sounds well and good,
but then the rich keep getting richer and the poor keep getting poorer and Jeff
Bezos shouldn't have,
you know,
$20 trillion or whatever he has right now or the rest of it.
What,
what's the,
what's the boiler plate answer to?
Why with those kinds of cliches because they've been around for 150 years and
they've never been true.
I mean that they weren't true and Marxists time and everybody got quickly
recognize that you're going to,
by the late 19th century,
uh,
in America we had,
we had built the most prosperous economy in the world by far,
by far,
by far growing incomes,
longer lives,
healthier people,
more opportunities for everybody.
People are moving to the cities.
Everybody's benefiting from capitalism.
That's been going on for such a long time and yet here we are in 2018 and we're
still recycling these,
these Victorian era cliches about capitalism.
I don't understand it.
What do you think capitalism then screwed up if if only just a marketing piece
of it or something where right now you sent and I believe that it will not win
but it somehow doesn't seem cool to be for capitalism,
at least with the Beatles seemed to be the change.
Maybe it's in the name and I don't,
I don't even have a problem not using the word capitalism.
I mean we would probably have the same view towards this.
I will speak the language that,
that you can understand and if I want to rebrand capitalism as liberalism,
which it probably should be actually liberal liberalism,
then I'm,
I'm glad to talk about that.
Uh,
same time,
I kind of liked the term capitalism.
I have no problem with you because,
because it,
it really does underscore really important point that without private property
and the in the,
and ownership of the means of production,
you can't have a complex,
uh,
production structures and you can't hire more people.
You can't,
you can't build great things.
You can have great cities,
you can't improve people's lives.
So what are the things that you think government should do?
Well,
I think of lots of kinds of rules that we should have.
Um,
but I'm not a fan of governments in general.
If there was some way that you could have,
you know,
an old fashioned liberal state,
that was really minded,
his own business and,
um,
kept kept civil war from happening,
for example,
you know,
kept conflict,
that kind of mass conflict,
um,
then that would be a probably a good,
a good thing.
Um,
state is not very good at that.
So,
um,
I,
I think,
I mean,
I've got,
I've got the mind of an anarchist essentially.
I trust,
you know,
I trust the chaos of,
of spontaneous human action much more than any kind of,
of of imposition.
Yeah,
but I,
but I am at same time.
I do like the writings of the old liberals,
you know,
they,
they imagined that the state should do something to keep something like order in
life.
It keeps civil war from happening to keep people from killing each other.
Terrible things like that.
But beyond that stage should just,
it should be a laissez faire.
It should just allow commerce to flourish and Lau Lau problems to work
themselves out.
I am.
People don't have confidence in that anymore,
but not because of any failure.
But it's almost like the,
the ideology of power has become a kind of a modern cancer that affects a flicks
everyone.
And I think we need to do something about it.
Wait,
can you explain that a little further?
Well,
it's just that once you believe that you can control the path of history and you
have an end point in mind,
society should look like this,
then you want to use every kind of tool to hammer it in place.
And this is,
this is what I call right and left wing Regalian Isam essentially.
And it's a,
it's a grave temptation.
And so we built this,
like we said,
at the outside,
and we built this gigantic machinery we call the state,
this total state and a controls.
So much wealth and so much power and so much rests with,
with getting,
you know,
gaining access to it that it just a kind of a constant moral hazard for
everybody.
Like give,
give me that state and I'll make it do the right things.
Right?
So for the people that on either side of this,
whether you're on the left and,
and you want to help those that you deem oppressed more people with less,
when I believe their intentions to be good,
even if their methodology I think generally is not good.
Or your people on the right that was less than a state,
but you know,
you're just on either side of this thing.
How much do you think the system itself can move without breaking?
Because what I think I'm noticing now is that there's a certain amount of people
that really just want to trash the whole thing.
And I do see this certainly more on the left right now because they're not
empower that there's this growing thing,
uh,
and this is why they're so into Marxism and all this stuff now.
It's like,
let's just trash the whole freaking thing and forget all the goodness that this
is done.
And they're doing it from their iPhones.
And you know,
there's that sense of irony is not great,
but is there,
is there has to a system,
you mean,
is there just a certain amount that a system that's basically good can move
before it snaps?
And I would suspect that that's not much either way really.
Uh,
you mean the commercial structure right now or a comma or the lives are
capitalist structures.
I mean the state,
um,
you know,
what I see actually happening is the innovation is taking place so quickly.
It's actually out running the,
uh,
the capacity of government to control it.
And I think that's,
that's really exciting.
If I was going to look at one point of hope in the world is that the market and
the entrepreneurial innovative sectors of life from the APP economy to the Gig
economy to now with with blockchain technology and everything is moving so
quickly that states can't,
can't even keep up.
Right.
So I'm there with you on that because that's glorious.
I'm very happy about that and see that because it's,
to me it's like,
well how are people listening to all of these conversations,
all of these podcasts that are out there
and communicating about them so quickly and it's like the government can't,
I can't keep up with all of that.
The change can't because people are lighting up all the time now in a much
faster way and I think we're changing in a much more rapid way and I think
that's actually really cool.
There's a danger to it because we could just spin out of control and do all
sorts of awful things.
But what you said,
well,
what did you say before about the general inertia of people or something that
the general left to their own ways of figuring things out?
I'll figure it out.
And,
and you know,
there's a reason why or
politics seem reactionary on the left and the right,
everyone's trying to bring back something.
There's a,
there's a nostalgia on the left and an establish it on the right and they're
trying to use the state to hold us back like,
and,
and whatever.
It's a vision of the,
is it the 60s?
Is it,
is it the seventies?
Is it preindustrial revolution?
You know,
is it some risks?
So Ian Fantasy of perfectly quality and that the left might imagine,
or,
or the ride,
uh,
thinking about,
you know,
a world of high tariffs of the 1880s or nineties or,
but everyone's looking back to something that they want to create and there's a
real fear of the future,
future on the left and the right.
And it's a future without control.
It's a future where we're able to travel,
where we want to download the apps.
We want to invent what we want to work by ourselves.
Live where we want to live,
be digital nomads,
tr,
you know,
traveled around.
Do what we want this,
this will,
that's so cool.
That's not what people should be fearing people.
Everyone should be going,
holy cow,
this is the free is coolest thing ever.
That's the world I want to live in.
I want to land.
That obviously is why you're so attracted to bitcoin also.
Right?
In crypto in general.
Sure.
Cause it's sort of the backbone.
Well out of this.
I mean if you think about it,
I mean we've waited our whole lives and actually generations of great
intellectuals have lived,
lived in diet for so long,
wanting something like a private currency that that emerged privately,
that operates without financial intermediaries,
that the government is not controlling,
that it's global.
That doesn't,
it's not restrained by currency zones that anyone can have access to.
You know,
a true democratic technology like bitcoin or any cryptocurrency.
That is just a dream come true.
That is glorious.
That's why I write about it all the time and talk about it all the time.
It is,
it is the outright killer.
It is the alt left killer.
It's the thing that's going to ultimately,
I think,
um,
protect us from these wicked ideologies that are constantly trying to control
their lives.
Because basically at some point,
one of these ideologies is going to get too much control of the state have just
financially
forever.
I mean,
you know,
one of the things that,
that when I think about this,
sometimes when you get depressed about the divisions in our public life,
in the way people are tearing,
tearing each other apart,
and the way you opened up the newspaper and you can barely even read it anymore,
you know,
it was like,
yeah,
I know,
but it's like Donald Trump,
you then it's like,
you know,
I'll put Trump,
and it's just,
it's just this forever debate.
And the one thing that I think maybe we should not be entirely unhappy about
this.
As you look back at history,
when freedom emerges out of the high middle ages,
it wasn't because any one great intellectual or anyone great state or anyone
great power said,
hey,
let's let everybody be free.
It was because there's so many competitors for power.
They,
nobody could gain.
The monopoly was the church,
it was the nation state,
it was the localities on monarchical state,
uh,
the,
the landed aristocracy,
you know,
the,
the rise of the merchant class,
you know,
so there are all these independent power centers strewn throughout European
society and nobody could get,
get access to the finals,
single singular control,
no unitary power.
And so that fight that took place amongst so many disparate powers,
that actually led to a kind of flourishing of freedom.
So you know,
and a sense,
the fight between the left and the right today is not the worst thing if they
just keep fighting and leave the rest of us alone.
Right,
right,
right.
All right,
so [inaudible] we're going to be that lucky,
but okay.
So before we spend the whole second half on the question that I started this
whole thing with,
do the people who want freedom basically and a light touch of government,
are they always added disadvantage because there's another set of people who
will always use the apparatus against them where if they're being true to
themselves,
they won't use the power to stifle of their people.
There are all sorts of other things.
So in an odd way,
our ideas are at a distance.
They always have been.
We've always been a kind of minority.
So even again over the last two or 300 years of political history,
I've always been that third way.
That's fine.
Minority.
But we had,
we had rare victories but big ones,
you know,
like the end of slavery,
um,
was just glorious.
I mean the protection of the great banking empires of Europe from,
from the populace rabble,
you know,
from the,
from the preachers who wanted to destroy it.
There were these great victories of the victory of free trade,
you know,
but,
but we've won every once while,
and it always changed the world because once you have a little bit of freedom,
just a little bit,
it just blows up and it becomes awesome.
And it's amazing and it,
and it kills power because it's so powerful and so wonderful,
but it's worth fighting for.
And we've always fought mainly through ideas,
not through army's,
not through,
through guns and controlling states.
It's always been the philosophical awesomeness of this position has been the
celebration of the common man,
uh,
celebration of,
of wealth,
of the love of,
of consumerism and commercial life for the coming together of people they noble
meant of people that the,
the right of,
of travel,
uh,
the right of association and to do what you want to have as many children as you
want,
to educate your kids the way you want to,
that these kinds of principles are compelling and they've always led to victory
for liberals despite the pressure from the other two sides.
And I think that's,
I think it's going to be our future.
I do.